Tại sao dự thào lột đại sờ đổi giữa bộ nung nghiệp ở mối triển lấy kiến ngoài
thích trường hợp đăng được cuy định trong lợp đại nè mang những không tràm tư.
Sờ thào bầu xung cuy định không cấp dây trình nhận đối với thử ở đất đã
có thông bảo thù của đất có hiệu lực theo cuy định.
Đối với trường hợp đáp của cuy định thù của đất thì thục không cấp dây trình nhận
chứ trường hợp đáp qua bản tham kể từ ngày bắt hành cuy định mà chứ thực hiện việc
thu hồi.
Sờ thào cũng thích thục cuy định không cấp dây trình nhận đối với đất thay
thay lại của người xu dụng đất.
Chưa chúng hợp thời đất của chù đồng tư xây dựng
kinh suàng tích cấu hạ tăng theo dựa đực cơ quan của thông quyền phía dụng
đất nhận khoảng, chưa chúng hợp đất công nhận của người xu dụng đất thông cuy định của pelot
thử đất đàn có chính chấp, quyền xu dụng đất đàn bị kê biến
ám dụng biển pháp bảo đam phía hành ám, hòa miển pháp hình cấp tạm thời.
Đối với tại sản gắn liền với đất dự thảo thử thu của định không cấp dây trình nhận
đối với nhà ở công chính xây dựng trên thử đất không đều đu kiện đựng cấp dây trình nhận
nhà ở công chính xây dựng tạm, tài sản đã có thông bảo hòa quy định dạy
cho đất, chưa thực hiện thu hồi.
công chính xây dựng sau thời điểm có bố cảm xây dựng
không chính lần, chiếm hành là bảo vệ công chính hạ tăng ký thuật.
Dưới thích lịch sự banh hoa hóa không phùa quy quy định thảo quy định.
Theo cửa quan sản thảo, xói đi ông một năm một lợi đại ngã mà nhìn không chăm tư,
hòa hệ thực quy định về các trường hợp không được cấp dây trình nhận được giữ quan.
Điểm thấy đổi đáng truyết là bộ xong thường hợp thử đất đả có thông bảo thử đất,
còn hiệu lực vào xanh mục không được cấp dây trình nhận.
Theo sự thảo giữ thảo lợp đất đại sự đổi dưới đất quy bán thử vụ của hội thảo lợp
cho ý kiến trong được thật thứ 2 của phíanh họp thử tư.
Dên xác tương nghe, hôm nay thống bệnh đi vinh hệ bán người thống bệnh.